-Guys, it is time for "Tonight
Show" Hashtags. Here we go.
♪ -Hashtags ♪
♪♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Well, we do this thing every
week where I send out a hashtag
and I ask you guys
to respond to that topic.
So with the infrastructure bill
recently passing,
I sent out the hashtag
#TheyNeedToFix.
And I asked you guys to share
a weird or funny problem
that needs a solution.
Yeah. Within minutes,
it was a trending topic,
so thank you for playing along.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite responses
from you guys.
Here we go.
This first one is
from @kansasbradbury.
He says,
"They need to fix it so food
has three different
expiration dates --
one date that says 'Best
before,' then one called
'still pretty good' and finally,
'Are you feeling lucky?'"
[ Laughter and applause ]
I like that.
-I love it.
-Beats the sniff test.
-Yeah.
This one's from @ahnah96.
-Ahnah?
-Ah, nah.
-Ah.
[ Laughter ]
-Could be Anna.
-What does she say?
-She says, "They need to fix
how they package scissors.
To remove the packaging,
you need scissors.
If I had a pair of scissors
in the first place,
I wouldn't need to buy
another one."
[ Applause ]
"Honey, get me
the scissor-opening scissors."
This is from @bakeross1988.
He says, "They need to fix songs
that have
police or ambulance sirens
in them,
so when you're listening to them
in a car,
a voice says, 'This is not real.
Do not pull over.'"
[ Laughter ]
Yes! I agree with that!
-Yes!
I totally agree with that.
This one is from
@dundermifflin84.
-Oh, wow.
-He says, "They need to fix beer
prices at sports games.
$10 is unacceptable.
Unless I've already
had three beers,
then $10 is
perfectly acceptable."
[ Laughter and applause ]
I love that.
This is from @breesweetack.
She says, "Our phones are
powerful, tiny computers
that can fit in our pocket,
but vending machines still can't
recognize a dollar bill
with a crease in it?"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Fix it!
This one is from
@onufreyonboard.
He says, "They need to fix
restrooms in movie theaters
so that there are restrooms
in each theater with screens
showing the movie,
so if you need to go,
you don't miss anything."
-Ooh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Nice.
-Wow.
-Yeah.
-Really?
-Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah.
-Oh, I say absolutely not.
-What?
I always go to the bathroom
at the part
that is the crux
of the whole movie.
-I know, but you never leave
the theater.
-Well, no, but I go to
the bathroom.
[ Laughter ]
-You got those astronaut...?
-I got the astronaut diapers.
Made a big splashdown.
[ Laughter ]
-This one is from @carlsochill1.
-Ah.
-He says, "They need to make
pizza boxes that can actually
fit inside a refrigerator.
Takes up the entire space
just for one slice
that I'm going to eat
at 2:00 a.m."
That's right.
[ Applause ]
Come on.
This last one is
from @lotsofmiles.
He says, "They need to fix
cereal bags.
Please. Talk to Ziploc."
-Oh!
-There you have it, everybody.
Those are our
"Tonight Show" hashtags.
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.